[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana y lo vamos a hacer
regularmente ponemos el foco ya en las
elecciones presidenciales de abril aquí
en francia elecciones 2022 vamos a
analizar un ángulo y vamos a analizar la
crisis de la izquierda francesa a dos
meses de las elecciones para ello
contamos en este estudio con guillermo
arenas docente investigador en derecho
público miembro del 'think tank'
hemisferios hemisferio izquierda
bienvenido guillermo buenos días gracias
contamos también con mi compañera
periodista política independiente de
l'or comet y bienvenida gracias y enric
con el corresponsal del diario el
periódico aquí en francia bienvenido
enric hola gracias por la invitación la
crisis de la izquierda francesa hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
la izquierda francesa sufre del peor mal
que una campaña electoral puede ofrecer
mucho intento de líder para tan poco
votante ilusionado con los sondeos en la
mano ninguno de la decena de candidatos
de izquierda se cuela entre los cuatro
primeros puestos del ranking que siguen
ocupando el presidente macrón los
ultraderechistas lepén y fémur y la
conservadora valérie pécresse la
división es total entre socialistas
ecologistas comunistas e izquierda
radical y entre todas las candidaturas
forman una nebulosa condenada al fracaso
a dos meses de las elecciones que tiene
difícil solución que le pasa a la
izquierda francesa porque la
ultraderecha ha conseguido conquistar a
votantes que en el pasado votaron por
opciones de izquierda su sentencia a
muerte es definitiva y si así fuese hoy
nos queremos preguntar a ampliar el zoom
y preguntarnos de forma filosófica y a
partir del ejemplo francés que es hoy en
día sigue izquierdas repasemos antes
algunas portadas que nos ofrece la
prensa el diario libération dedicaba
esta portada a otra nueva candidatura de
izquierdas la de la ex ministra de
justicia cristian tu vida la última en
subirse a esta carrera presidencial que
desde luego más clarificar las cosas lo
que ha supuesto es una fragmentación aún
mayor diario le parisien se pregunta si
precisamente la alcaldesa de la capital
la socialista anne hidalgo va a aguantar
su campaña hasta el final sabiendo que
los sondeos apenas le otorgan un 4 por
ciento de intención de voto la cual
titula en esta otra portada que el macro
nismo sigue siendo un enigma ideológico
de fácil adaptabilidad y que ya hay más
de uno que se pregunta si dadas las o
las demás opciones la izquierda va a
terminar refugiándose en macrón como mal
menor
bueno si tuviesen que explicar un
espectador o poco familiarizado con la
política francesa porque la izquierda de
este país está sufriendo esta crisis tan
agónica cuando quedan dos meses para las
elecciones presidenciales guillermo que
claves habría que buscar bueno la
primera es que la izquierda desde los
años ochenta ha existido alrededor de un
polo central que es el partido
socialista que ha gobernado francia
durante 14 años y que a partir de 2012
de 2017 perdón con la aparición de
macrón en la escena política se ha
fragmentado completamente y ha dejado un
espacio vacío que diferentes partidos
intentan ocupar ahora con un éxito
bastante variable los claves para
explicar un votante que un oyente desde
américa latina que no entienda por qué
esta crisis de la izquierda yo estoy
totalmente de acuerdo con guillermo y
añade añadiría que también hay una
impresión de desorden para bueno para
los electores franceses de izquierda
porque hay muchas candidaturas no sé no
se entiende muy bien porque no hay
uniones y parece que también hay muchas
candidaturas un poco
y gocen del gas a candidatos que no
quieren abandonar por una cuestión de
sobrevivencia política y no realmente de
pragmatismo programático con la paradoja
de que muchos de ellos llaman a la unión
llaman a una unión y no están alrededor
de sí mismos enric relacionado con lo
que comentaba guillermo yo creo que la
razón principal de declive de la
izquierda en francia es del mandato muy
decepcionante de françois blond que
buena parte del electorado de izquierdas
considera una traición por sus políticas
económicas su mano muy dura
por eso cuando tuvo que responder a los
atentados proponiendo medidas como la
quitar la nacionalidad de los acusados
por terrorismo está en profunda
decepción del
género lawn ha hecho que el partido
socialista en planteada se encuentra
ahora en una situación crítica casi
acerca de desaparecer y desde entonces
desde 2017 ninguna de las otras fuerzas
de izquierdas como iu han podido
reemplazar a este partido socialista no
ha conseguido salúm verizon con la
frente sumisa que es un populismo
izquierdas parecido a la izquierda
latinoamericana tuvo su oportunidad pero
no lo termino de conseguir y tampoco los
verdes que hubieran tenido su
oportunidad no lo han conseguido y esto
lo que hace el programa actual una
situación muy complicada de la izquierda
para estas elecciones hablarían ustedes
de votantes desilusionados como está
ahora mismo la gente que ustedes conocen
de izquierdas ahora mismo cómo enfocan
estas elecciones a dos meses de las
elecciones en qué situación anímica se
encuentran cómo es esa sociología de
izquierdas ahora mismo cómo está el
votante de izquierdas el votante de
izquierdas está efectivamente
desilusionado y decepcionado
no entiende cómo lo habéis dicho que no
haya mayores dinámicas de unión
alrededor de candidatos que podrían
ellos tener opciones de pasar a la
segunda vuelta en estas elecciones hay
una incomprensión también hay diría una
distancia y esto es algo bastante grave
cada vez más importante entre la
izquierda de partidos los responsables
políticos y la izquierda militante la
sociedad civil organizada de izquierdas
y de hecho hay una paradoja por un lado
tenemos una sociedad civil muy móvil
como movilizaciones importantes en favor
del clima en contra del racismo etcétera
y por otro lado una izquierda de
partidos muy
poco movilizada muy poco dinámica e
incapaz de pues esto ver más allá de sus
propios intereses muy personales no
vamos a analizar algunas de las caras la
última en llegar a llegar a esta
nebulosa de candidatos de la que hablaba
luego hace un momento ha sido la ex
ministra de justicia cristian tuviera
popular por impulsar el matrimonio
igualitario durante el quinquenio de
françois hollande lo hizo ganando una
especie de primaria hecha a su medida y
organizada por sus propios seguidores
que el resto de candidatos tachan más de
publicitaria que de primaria real que
opciones reales tendría tu vida ahora
mismo lo su situación es complicada no
porque bueno salió vencedora de esta
primaria popular con un poco menos de
400 mil votantes no están mal pero bueno
pero ahora tiene esta misión casi bueno
me sale imposible
de construir una unión en la izquierda
pero bueno aparentemente hubo una
reunión con el equipo de anillado el
candidato ecologistas pero cada uno está
en su propia agenda me parece es
complicado para decir que bueno el radón
no quiere abandonar y seguirá creciendo
tu vieja y ella tampoco con este mandato
de la primaria popular está en una
posición como para decir que va a
renunciar y sostener apoyar a otro
candidato
si yo creo que lo tiene muy complicado
parecía que después de ganar estas
primarias sus simpatizantes de despensa
pensaban que iba a tener una dinámica a
su favor y en realidad esa dinámica
prácticamente no existió un impulso a
través de eso exacto y lo que el
contrario que está bajando los sondeos
porque no tiene programa su candidatura
a menudo da la sensación de mucha
improvisación de hecho la pasada semana
tuvo varias intervenciones mediáticas
bastante bastante en bocas y
catastróficas donde se mostró muy torpe
defendido pudiera ser una candidata
importante porque es una ex ministra de
justicia como hemos comentado que
legalizó el matrimonio homosexual que es
lo que hace una parte de la izquierda
que es un símbolo pero el hecho de que
se tenga una candidatura muy improvisada
también el hecho que se asocie mucho al
mandarle from sound etc yo creo que lo
tiene bastante complicado de todos los
candidatos de izquierdas por ahora el
que más apoyo tiene rozando el 10% y el
único que parece que podría colarse en
el pelotón de cabeza es ya en look me
dan son que de hecho en 2017 ya estuvo a
punto de meterse en la segunda vuelta
como ven sus opciones les sigue
lastrando el hecho de que no pueda
llegar a tener un voto útil centrista
porque sigue pareciendo un poco radical
para una buena parte del votante
socialdemócrata podríamos decir para mí
- o es el único candidato de izquierdas
ahora mismo que hace campaña y que hace
campaña para ganar unas elecciones
presidenciales el resto hacen campaña
para contarse al final de esas
elecciones y ver quién puede tomar el
liderazgo de un espacio político de
centroizquierda
- entonces hace campaña tiene un
programa muy serio tiene un equipo tiene
militantes etcétera pero efectivamente
bueno parece que hay una especie de
limitación que es que uno no hace ningún
esfuerzo para precisamente crear una
unión antes de la primera vuelta y
efectivamente tiene un programa asumido
y
en el cual en diferentes temas pues
después pues pues hay contradicciones
importantes con el resto de los
candidatos de izquierdas pues eso hace
eficiente que un elector medio de
izquierdas pueda difícilmente adherir a
la totalidad de su programa muchos de
nuestros dientes espectadores se
preguntarán entonces dónde está el voto
obrero aquí en francia
porque habría que buscar quizá en la
opción de la ultraderecha no sé si claro
aparece por varias encuestas de
sociólogos o por sondeos parece que el
voto obrero no se ha movido pero ya hace
bastante bastantes acciones hacia el pp
el osasuna nacional creo que a por lo
menos 40 por ciento de los obreros en
francia piensan que van a votar por eso
en la primera vuelta en abril porque
está producido ese trasvase de un
votante de izquierdas que en su momento
podía votar opciones más de izquierdas
como acaba votando a la extrema derecha
como podríamos explicar este fenómeno
creo que hay varias dinámicas primero
los partidos de izquierda caras que las
que han movido un poco su discurso que
sus discursos y sus programas están
menos centrados en la clase obrera al
mismo tiempo el amazon lema nacional y
sobre todo más y nos ven
ha movido un poco desde el liberalismo
económico hacia más proteccionismo y un
discurso un poco más social y bueno esto
hace que hoy la clase obrera defensa
bueno masivamente sea más tiene usa no
vota pero cuando votan votan más para el
partido unace imagínate quizá porque
haya candidatos enrique que desde el
ecologismo los obreros hayan
interpretado que el ecologismo otras
banderas de la izquierda se pertenecen a
un estatus muy urbanita y muy un poco
desconectado con ellos sí bueno es
cierto que en francia y esta dinámica
porque también sucede la buena parte de
los países europeos deben en eeuu de que
la izquierda basados en el partido de
los obreros a ser al partido de la gente
que tiene como más estudios
lo que el economista thomas thomas
piketty llamada la izquierda bragman y
acá pero que decir que la izquierda
los principales elementos para
determinar si una persona va a votar a
la izquierda o no ha venido es respecto
al nivel de estudios nacional ángela
izquierda son gente con niveles de
estudios elevados pero con niveles de
riqueza menos bajos que una parte de
votante más de centroderecha y esto y
esta transformación de votante de
izquierdas ha hecho que ha favorecido
una tendencia de que la izquierda se
haya ido alejando poco a poco del
votante obrero y quizás las nuevas
uno de los desafíos que tiene la
izquierda sería intentar reconciliar
finalmente estas clases medias con las
clases trabajadoras que es básicamente
la base que fue la socialdemocracia
durante el siglo 20 que ahora ha
cambiado por la sociología de la de los
países europeos ha cambiado mucho pero
es verdad que esta alianza yo creo que
no es imposible y el gran desafío que
podría tener la izquierda pero qué
momento ahora parece muy complicada
porque como hemos comentado sobre todo
votante popular está muy muy alejado de
estos partidos y es claro que es el
urbanita ir en bici a la tienda bío a
comprar a eso necesitas un estatus
económico cuanto menos no sí sí sin duda
sin duda y también hay algo que mal
independence un ser obrero movilizado
mucho en su en su discurso y es uno un
elemento anti establishment muy fuerte y
en ese sentido evidentemente atrae el
voto de protesta y un discurso muy
proteccionista es decir un discurso anti
el libre mercado en el marco de la unión
europea un discurso de protección
también de la industria francesa o de
los trabajadores franceses frente a la
competencia internacional entonces eso
evidentemente como decía lo ha pasado de
un discurso liberal un discurso más bien
proteccionista que hace hay gente que se
siente desprotegida vaya a buscar la
protección de una madre presidenta no
vamos a seguir analizando la crisis de
la izquierda a vuelta de pausa en
seguida hasta ahora
en 2020 cuatro años después del
referendo de salida del reino unido- del
bloque europeo y de tensas negociaciones
el break sheet es un hecho para europa
el reino unido decidió irse solo para
los partidarios de esta división es un
triunfo que hemos vencido todos los
pronósticos la victoria más inesperada
de los tiempos modernos
pero allí problemas como el rechazo a la
inmigración la violencia y la fractura
irlandesa continúan todo se ha tirado a
la basura traer estabilidad
debido al break si los extranjeros se
sienten mal con los británicos y no
vuelven
boleto de vuelta breves y de año 1 en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
cada 30 minutos france24 les ofrece una
actualización de los acontecimientos más
importantes de américa latina y el
número últimas noticias contexto y
análisis todo lo que necesita saber para
estar bien informado
noticias en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
la semana analizando la crisis de la
izquierda francesa a dos meses de las
elecciones presidenciales lo hacemos con
el docente guillermo arenas y los
periodistas lord cometí y enric bonet
bueno dada la situación actual con
ningún candidato de izquierdas entre los
cuatro que dominan los sondeos que sería
macro en los dos ultra derechistas fémur
y lepe y la conservadora de valérie
pécresse la reelección de macrón les
pregunto a los tres sería el menor mal
que le puede pasar a mi esposa a la
izquierda cómo está la situación mandra
nació de la izquierda o en todo caso del
pea es que se estaba descomponiendo
desde el partido socialista que estaba
descomponiendo atrás durante el
quinquenio durante el mandato de holanda
y entonces es evidente que parte gran
parte del electorado ex electorado
socialista va a seguir votando amac con
la falta de una alternativa creíble y
entusiasmante si expresa que se haya
comentado que durante el quinquenio él
ha defraudado a la parte más de
izquierdas que le pudo votar en 2017 por
sus políticas liberales se habla desde
nuestra elección de o no yo no soy
seguro de eso yo creo que la que el
electorado socialista que votó por el
2017 parecía muy claro que iba a hacer
el programa o sea que le va a conducir
el programa que ha conducido no creen
que en una eventual segunda vuelta entre
macro ni un candidato de la ultraderecha
la izquierda puede ser muy
abstencionista o quizá ponernos un
adjetivo más muy peligrosamente
abstencionista a la hora de dar pies a
la ultraderecha lo parece que sí porque
leí unos sondeos y bueno parece que en
casos de mccomb contra el open o ese
muro o aún varias veces
hay una valuación pero entre el 40 y el
60 por ciento de los votantes por
ejemplo de disminución podrían
decidir no ir a votar pero ojo que en
este momento estamos a dos meses de la
elección y parece también que el
electorado sigue muy volátil o sea que
muchos electores dicen que todavía no
tienen muy claro para quién van a votar
pero bueno podría ser un
una abstención histórica ya que en el
2017 una obsesión en una elección
presidencial en francia a un nivel de
récord esta desafección podría
traducirse en abstencionismo si yo creo
que es una de las claves de estas
elecciones a ver si va a haber unos
niveles de abstención altos normalmente
en francia las presidenciales los
niveles de participación son elevados
alrededor del 80 por ciento no es cierto
que las últimas elecciones que han
habido en francia las municipales de
2020 las regionales de del año pasado
hubo niveles de abstención récords que
subieron por encima en torno al 65 por
ciento y ahora claro es uno de los
grandes de las grandes interrogantes de
estas elecciones a ver cuál va a ser el
nivel de participación sea un nivel de
participación más bien alto alrededor
del 75 80 por ciento o bajo del 65 por
ciento y relacionado con todo lo que
hemos comentado en la izquierda yo creo
que esto al final es pues una de las
grandes claves de estas elecciones
porque es el nivel de participación es
alto finalmente es decir muchos jóvenes
van a votar obreros esto sí que podría
dar quizás una una parte una sorpresa de
una caída de izquierdas que podría hacer
un buen resultado incluso
colarse en la segunda vuelta porque es
cierto que en esas elecciones parece que
el umbral para para pasar a la segunda
vuelta va a ser bajo porque el voto de
la otra derecha se va a dividir entre
macro ni lepe y la conservadora p cresta
está bastante baja hasta entre el 14% si
cabe resaltar sólo un punto de contexto
no solamente la izquierda está
fragmentada sino que la derecha también
está históricamente fragmentada entonces
eso hace como tú dices que el que el que
el nivel que hace falta para pasar a la
segunda vuelta sea bastante bajo que
pueda efectivamente haber pues estar
haber sorpresas en nombraba enric las
últimas elecciones que fueron las
municipales si los recuerdan las
municipales del año pasado fue un gran
triunfo para el partido verde que llegó
a las alcaldías conquistó muchísimas
alcaldías en cambio ahora nos
encontramos con los sondeos que su líder
y anillado tiene dificultades para
sobrepasar el 5 el 6 por ciento
porque ese impulso de entonces y ahora
que tanto hablamos de ecología no se
traduce ahora en un impulso a los verdes
bueno porque las elecciones municipales
y la presidencia funcionan un poco
diferente mente creo que los electores
no votan de la misma manera y con la
misma
filosofía
pero nos has preguntado antes que es que
sienten los electores de izquierdas y
ecologistas y los ecologistas con quién
me encuentro también tiene un poco de
incomprensión o sea que ellos mismos no
entienden por qué iniciado está tan bajo
en los sondeos y hay una forma un poco
de distribución e incomprensión pero
parece que la me parece que la campaña
de haya linchado no es tan eficaz como
por ejemplo la edición y mi nación no
logra realmente imponer una o dos
medidas un poco más interesante eso que
que la gente va a discutir o
si es un poco
una distribución para los verdes a lo
que dice lo les añado otra pregunta se
ha diluido el valor ecologismo la
bandera ecologismo está en otras
opciones se ha hecho transversal con el
ecológico liberalismo de macrón el eco
proteccionismo del epen o el
ecosocialismo de hidalgo esto ha podido
pasar es decir que nos encontramos con
que el ecologismo no es una exclusividad
de los verdes sí sí es evidente que no
se escude que no es una actitud que
tienes una exclusividad que no tiene en
el monopolio de la ecología es también
como lo hice el ojo las características
de la elección presidencial son como se
dice en francia el encuentro entre un
hombre y el pueblo no sé y en ese en
este contexto y anillado no consigue no
consigue generar esta adhesión y esta
figura digamos presidencialista no pre
presidencial
si es verdad que los verdes podrían
tener la ventaja de que
el original y la copia
las europeas de 2019 pero yo creo que la
diferencia es que en las presidenciales
en francia la gente que va a votar el
ecologismo es una cuestión muy
importante un gran desafío de esta época
uno de los grandes pues para que la
gente no solo va a votar por el
ecologismo a votar también pensando en
el poder adquisitivo que es la
dificultad que tiene mucha gente ahora
en francia de llegar a fin de mes no
llegar a fin de mes con una vida cómoda
no es verdad que final mucha gente pues
claro a social no socia que el candidato
verde ya no va a responder a todas estas
cuestiones no por ejemplo una cosa que
suele hacer daño al ecologismo es cuando
desde desde los verdes haya habido
dirigentes que hayan defendido que es
positivo que aumente el precio de la
gasolina ahora por ejemplo en francés
está completamente disparado esto claro
eso aleja una parte importante del
electorado del voto de los verdes y los
reduce finalmente a un poco a su núcleo
duro que alrededor del 5 o 10 por ciento
y luego está la agenda de tema es verdad
que del ecologismo no se está hablando
quizá tanto como fuera necesario en esta
campaña
adquisitivo y luego está hay temas que
la izquierda le incomoda por ejemplo el
encaje del islam en francia y sobre todo
el tema de la seguridad que es un tema
del que se habla en francia y que
permanentemente la izquierda se siente
incómoda a la hora de tratarlo quizá
esto también tiene que ver con que la
gente no sienta afección porque la
izquierda es lucha este tipo de asuntos
sí yo creo que hay dos cosas hay un
fenómeno doble por un lado eficiente un
bloqueo por parte de la izquierda en
tratar una serie de temas que son temas
importantes para una gran parte de
franceses y por otro lado la incapacidad
de la izquierda en imponer sus propios
temas entonces claro si uno no puede
imponer su tema clave y al mismo tiempo
no está dispuesto a discutir temas que
otros imponen y que parecen ser
importantes el resultado es la dilución
la inexistencia y al final pues la
incapacidad para ser audible no
los fantasmas crecen poco a poco a dos
meses de las elecciones porque les
recuerdo que
incluso se están arriesgando los
partidos porque si no llegan al 5 por
ciento del voto necesario para que un
partido pueda es necesario ese 5% para
poder recuperar los gastos de campaña
claro eso que le pasó a otros partidos
de acuerdo pero que el partido
socialista se encuentre sin poder
recuperar los gastos de campaña con anne
hidalgo esto sería una si un terremoto
político en este país un terremoto bueno
una crisis histórica para el partido
socialista un desastre económico para el
partido que ya tuvo que mudarse a fuera
fuera de parís por razones financieras y
no sería sería un desastre además me
parece que lo que pasó cuando el
candidato socialista en el 2017 parecía
como bueno un error
algo del pasado pero ahora parece que
algo va a estar aún bajo de
los 6 % que ha tenido así que no sería
realmente creo que para el partido
socialista fin del punto de vista
financiero va a ser muy pero me parece
que añade algo no puede renunciar porque
sería aún peor y después de la
presidencia hay las legislativas y
ningún partido quiere desaparecer de la
primera vuelta hablando de renuncias
fusiones en los dos meses que quedan
puede haber movimientos en la izquierda
en riesgo quizás sí por los negocios
están demasiado fosilizados donde en el
crol han era algo tiene todo a punto
para continuar porque como ha comentado
la compañera básicamente un partido
centenario con el partido socialista no
se puede permitirnos estar presente en
las grandes elecciones de en francia son
las presidenciales en el caso de los
verdes yo creo que van a continuar
también porque yo creo que las redes de
los verdes es sobre todo pensar en 2027
ahora estamos por delante los
socialistas controlamos de un liderazgo
de la izquierda decía me despierto y
debilitada y aspiramos a ganar en 2027
las próximas presidenciales pero sí que
puede haber cambios desde mi punto de
vista quizás en el caso de cristian toba
ha llegado el último momento un poco una
candidatura un poco improvisado quizás
podría llegar a renunciar por un lado
por el poder por el mismo carácter de su
candidatura improvisada y luego otro
elemento es que en francia para
presentarse hace un falta de 500 avales
hay que disponer los a principios de
marzo y de momento tiene muy pocos se
puede descargar acá final no los
obtengan un par de asientos más un
asunto de actualidad en las últimas
horas mucho se habla de ese nuevo
movimiento desestructurado llamado
convoy de la libertad que intenta llegar
a parís y de ahí a bruselas contra las
restricciones sanitarias lo ven como un
resurgimiento de los chalecos amarillos
que pueda tener cierto impacto dos meses
de campaña es muy difícil ahora mismo
saber de qué está hecho este movimiento
pero parece evidente que parte de los
chalecos amarillos que se movilizaron en
2018 contra las subidas del precio del
carburante
están ahí no están están están
acompañando están apoyando y hacen parte
de este movimiento está muy temprano
saber de qué está hecho pero pero está
claro que asistimos cada vez más a
movilizaciones sociales
desestructuradas que no están conducidas
por un hilo ideológico claro que no son
el patrimonio de ningún partido político
tampoco y que son difíciles de analizar
y para los propios partidos políticos es
difícil
posicionarse con respecto a ellas
yo no les iba a preguntar si los
problemas de la izquierda francesa son
el apolo hable de otros países pero sí
que me gustaría a nivel casi filosófico
para acabar el programa preguntarles qué
es ser de izquierdas en 2022 o qué
valores se presuponen a este ticket alor
si es un trabajo que no hacen los
representantes políticos de la izquierda
realmente es difícil desde hoy porque me
parece que hay entre unión y caminamos
un o un año de algo y bueno hay claro
que hay puntos comunes justicia social
luchar contra las desigualdades
pero también hay hay diferencias
notables y por ejemplo me parece que la
visión de la sociedad de unión es menor
son por ejemplo qué
trata mucho de conquistar al voto en los
barrios populares y él mismo dice que
quiere luchar contra la islamofobia en
francia y por otra parte hay parte de
los socialistas que quieren quedarse con
la imagen de una república laica no
hablar mucho de religión y mucho menos
de islamofobia o sea que es un elector
viciada puede ser muy confundido y me
quedan unos segundos una frase para
acabar en rico guillermo una frase
completar lo que los decía yo creo que
es social ecología es el futuro
dedicamos la semana pasada el programa
cómo conjugar transición ecológica con
justicia social un gran reto para la
izquierda muchísimas gracias a los tres
y a todos ustedes les esperamos a quien
en primera plana la próxima semana
muchas gracias
[Música]